- I have to tell you this story.
So, I think having the double
mastectomy was the worst
and the drains they put
in, not to get too graphic,
I think it hit a nerve
so I was always fighting
with my doctors for more pain medication.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Okay, so there was a
day that drains were out,
gorgeous sunny day, feeling
free for the first time.
I had these plate glass
windows onto this patio
and wham, this little finch hit the window
and fell on the bricks dead and I went,
(deep exhale) "Great,
it's always something."
So, I opened the door
and I put him in my hands
and I sat out, you know how sometimes
you think you can heal something?
- Yeah like oh my God,
we're the same person.
- And then you think, oh it's
blasphemy, it's blasphemy.
- Yes (laughing) 'cause
you grew up in church.
- So, I'm sitting there
and all of a sudden,
he flips over in my hand and I mean,
his head was hanging off my hand before
and he flips over and I could
feel his tiny little claws
and then his wings were
fine, his beak was fine,
and my niece was there and
she's like the Francis of Assisi
of our family so she just said,
"Oh, he wants some water."
And I thought, dude, go.
And so we put a little cup of water
and we put her there and she
said, "Now, leave him alone."
(laughing)
'Cause she knows I wanna go mess with him,
but then I couldn't leave him alone
and I went back and he
flew off and I told Linda.
I said, "He flew away."
And she said, "Are you
getting the message?"
And at first, I thought,
I can heal like Jesus.
(audience laughing)
- Gimme some water.
- [Kathy] You know, right?
I'm gonna turn it into wine.
- Totally and she said, "No,
you thought you were dead,
"but now you can fly into a new life."
- Oh my gosh, I love your niece.
- I do too.
- [Kelly] Yeah, what
a beautiful sentiment.
- I mean, after that I just thought,
everything's gonna be okay.
- Yeah, those little moments man.
- [Kathy] Huge, I still get chills.
- They make huge impacts, yeah.
- And it's a moment of grace.
- [Kelly] And humility.
- [Women] Yeah.